hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing once again
Harry Potter and his immense stacks of
gold however the focus of today's video
examines Harry's riches from a bit of a
different angle looking at not just how
he acquired all of his gold but also at
how much gold he actually had I've done
this with the help of an R Harry Potter
Predator that I'll mention later on to
kick things off I'm going to Briefly
summarize why Harry was so rich then
we'll segue into the sheer volume of
gold that young Mr Potter actually
boasted Harry inherited his
herculean-sized piles of gold directly
from his parents of course but the
family fortune certainly didn't
originate with them so who did it start
with as it happens the Potter family
fortune began with the founding
patriarch of the Potter family Linford
of stinchcombe a 12th century potionaire
who found a great degree of success in
his profession Linford responsible for
creating remedies still used to this day
including skellagrow which repairs or in
some instances grows back broken bones
and the pep rub potion a cure for the
common cold that helps to warm the
Drinker up provided that lymphed potions
are still used in the modern era it
should come as no surprise that he was
able to earn quite a healthy living so
healthy in fact that he was able to stow
away much of his riches inside of the
Potter family Vault however the flow of
money certainly didn't end there as some
of flynnford's descendants decided to
continue in his footsteps the next
Potter to find success was Fremont
Potter Harry's grandfather and James's
dad who continued to invent potions and
rake in the cash during his lifetime
flimot took the family fortune and
quadrupled it by creating the famous
Sleek Easy's hair potion although flea
Mart never met Harry he unquestionably
set Harry up for Life as a large
majority of the gold inside Vault 687
was passed down down from him when
Harry's finally old enough to attend
Hogwarts he's brought to gringott's
fault 687 by Hagrid where he sees his
vast sacks of cash for the first time
inside his vault lies piles upon piles
of gold and today we're going to be
figuring out just how much gold young
Harry actually inherited with that said
however I can't move forward without
crediting the original mathematician
Behind these calculations Neo craters
read from Reddit I reached out to him
before creating this video and he said
he'd be happy for me to take a closer
look at his calculations so join me as
we take a look at the exact figures
inside Harry's Vault neocratos Begins by
stating the following so what I did was
a rough approximation of what would be
Harry Potter's wealth in terms of
current dollars or at least a minimum
estimate since there was no reference of
Harry's amount of money in the books the
closest Canon estimate we can get comes
from the Vault 687 as shown in the first
movie he then goes on to include three
screenshots showing Harry's piles of
gold from various angles screenshots
which will help us to better understand
the estimated volume
after sharing the three images of
Harry's gold he goes on to State the
following before beginning with his
instructions on how he actually went
about calculating Harry's Fortune you
could count the individual galleons but
what I did was a small estimate however
I summoned smarter ravenclaws to do
things better than me and get a better
result Step 1 measurements step one for
Neo Kratos red was measuring the width
depth and height of the main pile then
trying to include the coins from the
sides accompanying his words included
the image shown on screen 15 coins in
terms of depth approximately 75 coins in
terms of height approximately 25 coins
in terms of width I'm counting three
more layers out of the frame he then
States the following now this shape
resembles a pyramid and the formula for
its volume is given by an area of Base
times height times one-third so in this
case we have 25 times 30 times 75
divided by 3 equals 18 705
he also goes on to include that his
formula is correct but that the diagram
is a little off I labeled the diagonals
when in fact I wanted to label the edges
so the formula is still correct but the
picture is not after this he shifts his
attention to one of the other images of
Harry's gold as to gain a better
understanding the image reads 35
additional layers however as we can see
in this other frame the base of our
pyramid seems to be at the same level of
the pile of coins on the right so from
this picture we can assume that our
pyramid is at least 35 galleons higher
with the base that is at least the same
as ours so if we want to keep things as
low as possible we can assume a shape
like this one that added to our original
count brings the number of galleons of
the central pile to
18750 plus 35 times 30 times 25 equals
000. along with the diagram on screen he
adds we could consider the white part of
the shape but we don't know how find our
base is at the bottom so underestimating
things now should compensate for
eventual overestimation errors than
before next he says the following now
looking at the right pile we can
approximate its shape to half a box and
the volume gives us 5 times 10 times 35
divided by 2 equals 875 inches the image
reads 35 additional layers 10 depth 5
width finally on the left we have two
piles one in focus and one out of focus
a rough approximate gives us 10 times 10
times 25 divided by 2 equals 1 250
galleons I've considered half a box in
this case as well to compensate for any
overestimation the image reads 10 depth
25 height 10 width following this he
States the following but we don't have
to forget that these galleons are at the
same height of the base of the pyramid
so we need to add the additional 35
layers which multiplied by the base 10
times 10 gives us 1250 plus 10 times 10
times 35 equals
4750 and through this complex series of
calculations neocratus red was able to
determine that Harry had a minimum of 50
625 galleons in his volts the first time
he enters it this of course does not
account for gold that Harry had accrued
later in life I.E inheritance from
Sirius but it does highlight Harry's
level of wealth at the age of 11. if you
need a refresher on your Wizarding
currencies there are three coins that
are primarily circulated within the
Wizarding community in Britain galleons
sickles and knuts depreciating order but
now you might be asking what are they
worth how does a galleon compare to a US
dollar or a UK pound well first let me
give you the relative value of each form
of Wizarding currency one Galleon is
said to be equal to 17 sickles or 493
canards which makes one sickle
equivalent to 29 knots and according to
JK Rowling one Galleon is equal to about
five Great British pounds over the years
this assigned value of five pounds has
certainly been subject to copious
speculation including an assertion that
one Galleon equals 25 but as far as
sources go I'd say a quote from the
original author is pretty reliable in
the current market one Great British
pound is equivalent to about 1.227 US
Dollars which means that drum roll
please Harry had a minimum of 5 times 50
625 or 253
125 pounds in his vault that's 310
1724 US Dollars this does deviate from
neocrators reds total where He suggests
that Harry's net worth is a minimum of
1.265 625 million dollars or one million
638 pounds but that's only because we're
going off of different values for one
Galleon for his calculation he used a
figure supplied by a fellow Predator
that may have been calculated before the
quote from JK Rowling neocratus red also
goes on to include the following notes
regarding his calculations this does not
take into account other properties like
grimald place this was a minimum
estimate which means that I took all the
precautions of the case to underestimate
the actual wealth in the book we can
read Harry gasped inside were mounds of
gold coins Columns of silver heaps of
little bronze canads this means that
there were multiple mounds of gold coins
not just one and there was also silver
if we take into account the actual width
and depth of a vault we can see the
values Skyrocket to tens of millions
assuming the whole floor is covered in
gold and silver so I just tried to keep
things as low as possible overall I have
to take my hat off to neocrators Red so
I think that he did a stand-up job of
calculating the total value of Harry's
Vault particularly if we consider the
extremely limited resources at our
disposal and that's it for this video do
you agree with these calculations
disagree why please leave a comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
[Music]